hey everybody its charlie we got new
spider-man far from home footage to
breakdown we finally got confirmation on
what kind of a suit he's actually
wearing I know it looks a little bit
like spider-man noir so I'll try to
explain what's going on with that but it
just confirmed some things that we
thought based on the pictures that I
posted earlier this week so speaking of
spider-man two are there's a new round
of that spider-man ps4 game giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the video is obviously just a
continuation of spider-man's fight with
Mysterio at this big carnival that
they've been filming at it's been
doubling for Prague in the Czech
Republic like they actually just went
back to Venice so you probably seen some
behind the scenes pictures of them just
running around the canals like yep Tom
Hall on you have zendaya and then you
have the after the place and that leaves
just having fun this is them just
hanging out but they could always be
going back to Venice at some point to
reshoot some other footage but usually
what happens is is they try to shoot
everything that they need when they go
to new big cities so will be kind of
weird for them to take the entire
production back there but the important
thing about this I think is that they're
not doing it with a motion capture suit
they're actually doing with like a
physical suit that they'll probably
change a little bit in post-production
with special effects
you probably remember all the way back
to homecoming with all the behind the
scenes stuff that we saw him in a
physical suit doing that bike save this
is what the stark tech suit looked like
behind the scenes and then would it look
like in the same scene after they
finished post-production
so even though this version of the suit
looks much more like the stark tech suit
albeit with a spider-man noir twist it
still kind of seems like it's the stark
tech suit just in a stealth mode just
because of the way the eye pieces are I
think part of the reason why some
websites were reporting spider-man noir
is because when he turns his head a
little bit it looks kind of like he's
wearing goggles and that's mostly just
because of what the practical suit looks
like behind the scenes onset like when
they erase some of these lines in
post-production it looks just like the
normal costume albeit blacked-out
but the interesting thing is to when we
saw this black picture from the carnival
like okay maybe he's wearing the stealth
suit maybe it'll be more like camo mode
and people will see through him the
weird thing about that is that you would
think that they would use a motion
capture suit for stuff like that so
maybe they have some weird way of doing
it or maybe it's just black all the time
but you can see he has a belt on it and
obviously he uses his webbing so he
still has his regular web shooters those
are already black so it's not like you
need to change the colors for those so
everything about the way the costume
sits on him the cowl the web-shooters
the belt just makes it seem like it's
the same suit that he's had that Tony
Stark gave to him he just has some
functions that he's unlocked that he
didn't know about before I think that's
part of the fun of him getting Iron Man
tech back during homecoming is that it's
like this mystery box present that he's
gotten that he doesn't totally
understand
and part of the fun of these new movies
is just unlocking secret functions that
have been there the whole time he just
hadn't figured out yet would you like me
to engage enhanced combat mode enhanced
combat mode yeah activating instant kill
[Music]
the other thing about you know
quote-unquote
new costume in Spider Man far from home
is that I think we're all expecting him
to either modify a suit or make his own
suit at some point and it'll look a
little bit more like classic comic book
Spider Man and a little less like the
homecoming suit there was some concept
art a little while ago I did a video
about he was almost the same thing with
a slightly different spider symbol and
he didn't have the black lines of the
stark tech suit there's also some
separate unused concept art from
spider-man homecoming for a different
suit that they didn't end up going with
that a lot of people think might serve
as the basis for
but his newer version of the costume
will end up looking like eventually the
only difference here is I would say that
they would probably tune some of this
darker looking blue a slightly lighter
shade to make it a little more comic
boogie but you can kind of see with the
webbing it looks almost a little bit
more like the suit that they went with
during Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
era when they did the homecoming suit
they toned a lot of that webbing way way
down but the suit that he wore on the
set of civil war behind the scenes
actually did have quite a bit of it so
you can kind of tell that they changed
their minds a little bit through the
process like here's the version we're
gonna do while you're on set running
around and that by the time they get to
the end of special-effects they've
completely decided on a totally
different look for those of you hoping
for a Sheree collaboration because she's
supposed to be like the new smartest
person in the MCU most of the scenes
we've seen her in showcase this sense of
style that she has it's just really
really cool so I posted a clip a little
while ago of latisha right the actors
that plays Sheree talking about how her
and Peter's characters were talking
about ideas for upgrading his suit
during Avengers 4 man Tom's my friend
and I was I was contemplating helping
him in the future with his suit and
stuff and just we were just going back
and forth so what might end up happening
is is I'm not expecting a spider-man to
start running around in a vibranium suit
or anything like that but she might just
give him some style tips he makes the
suit and then enhances his webbing with
some wakandan technology that would seem
like the most practical way to
incorporate stuff from black panther so
that it still looks like spider-man like
you wouldn't know that they would have
any influence on any of his stuff unless
you saw another scene where he gets an
idea from Sheree like oh wow this is
actually a really cool idea so that's
really the level of my expectation when
it comes to Sheree spider-man
collaboration but hopefully they'll
appear in a movie at some point together
because of all that talk with the
spider-man villains that we're gonna
show up during the original version of
the Black Panther movie we haven't
really heard enough about what they're
doing with black panther 2 to start
theorizing about that so we'll probably
get some news about that after Avengers
4 comes out because in the comics if you
guys didn't see they just made Black
Panther the head of the New Avengers
team surprise surprise heading into
phase 4
you know real-life Robert Downey jr.
Chris Evans via
leaders of the Avengers sort of taking a
backseat to the new characters what a
coincidence that Black Panther becomes
one of the new leaders of the team but
I'm also expecting Captain Marvel during
phase four to shoulder some of that
burden but we'll be able to theory craft
a little bit more about that once we
actually start seeing Avengers 4 footage
so let me know in the comments what do
you want spider-man to do with the next
version of his costume and if he does
get some tips from Shuri about tricking
his suit out what do you want that to
actually end up looking like if you guys
haven't been playing spider-man ps4 you
can actually get the noir suit during
that this is what it looks like it's
just more of a jacket remember this is
supposed to be a 1930s version of
spider-man from an alternate universe
area secure
spider-man I'm sorry I was wrong about
you
Jameson could go to hell much
appreciated officer one question from
another world
yeah it's called Queens see yeah they've
been dropping some deleted scenes from
ant-man of the wasp in the quantum realm
so I might do a video for that tomorrow
but whatever my next Marvel video is
I'll just name the giveaway winner
during that click here for that new
venom trailer and click here to look at
Iron Man's new armor during Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]